raising money is not an accomplishment
raising money is you know it's an
obligation so the more you raise the
more of an obligation you have I'll show
you if you return a lot more than that
and they expect 10 20 times yeah five
would be like okay but yeah it'll it'll
it'll be more but but the important
thing is we're trying to build
high-impact products with it and we're
trying to kind of drive all of the
nonsense and inefficiency out of the
kind of conventional Silicon Valley
method for how we make products trying
to make things that make the world
better nonsense
what's the nonsense what do people it's
lookin Valley what's the cruft that's
build up now startups the idea of
startup startups are stupid all right
this ad I did this week in startups yeah
stories are stupid this is why our
startups do but impact this so I'm
investing a hundred are you tell me
they're stupid let's say you are a let's
look at any other creative industry okay
create a field let's say music let's say
you are one of the let's say you like
you're one of the one-in-a-million
Mozart level the most talented musicians
alike right you're just really good you
don't have to make a music company you
just play and the platforms have been
created YouTube and others where you're
gonna reach a billion people no because
you're sharply talented if you were the
most talented writers in the world you
don't have to start a writing company
you just write yeah if you want all most
talented filmmakers in the world you
don't have to start a movie studio you
make a movie at Netflix or HBO or
something like that but if you're one of
those talent it's like one in a million
Mozart level genius product people you
have to make a company first we have to
say oh okay you have this great idea to
change the world
great first become a mediocre CEO here's
the Wikipedia page on how to make a
startup deal with raising your seed
money in efficiency to building the
structure and the structure is built so
that you can have investors who get
shares and that's the architecture of
this is really the funding mechanic
who's making it so the structures built
for the benefit of the investors not or
not for the not optimized for creating
high-impact
products in an inclusive way you found
something better
well maybe we think so yeah and the
model works well in Silicon Valley like
because there's a lot of investors a lot
of really smart investors investors like
you like like like like other investors
who are here know what investment means
you like investors here understand that
when you invest in an entrepreneur
you're not doing them a favor you expect
that a lot of the time you're not gonna
see the money back like this is right
culture that's actually very rare like
it's very rare in the world to have
investors that understand what their
role is yeah
place a bet support the founder get out
of the way 70% chance of failure in a
lot of other places especially for
startups like investors think they're
doing you a favor when they invest
that's actually really bad mentality so
I experienced that in New York the
Silicon Valley model works okay here but
it's crippling and outside of this
country in everywhere else so what we're
basically trying to do what this our
model is is HBO it's Netflix we are
we're a studio in that sense we're a
studio like Netflix a studio where you
want to make innovative products
ourselves our own stuff attract great
people to do it make them distribute
them book the revenue go fullcycle learn
what we need to from the distribution to
influence what we make in the future
have-have platform effects and synergies
reuse as much of the sales structure
technology structure expertise structure
as you have make things in a disciplined
way